throughout stream 2 we see a few
glimpses of the movie stab which is
essentially the in-universe version of
stream 1. each character's stab
counterpart is played by a known actor
from our world and in the case of sydney
that actress is tori spelling which is
playing off a joke from the original
screen okay so just think if they make a
movie about you who's going to play you
i see you as a young meg ryan myself
thanks dewey with my lucky cast story
spelling at one point it suggested that
the new killer is trying to make an in
real life sequel to the happenings in
woodsboro from the year before and
scream 2 consequently features many
scenes that call back to the original to
learn the meaning behind this graffiti
stick around to the end of this video
and i'll be back when you guys start
talking about something a little more
saved by the belt
welcome to things you missed i am zack
morris as discussed in the last episode
stream one was a satire on horror movies
so naturally stream two satirizes
sequels in fact it openly acknowledges
that they're usually inferior to the
original so what's the deal here did
they intentionally make scream 2 an
inferior movie in the movie premiere
scene maureen gets flack from her fellow
moviegoers when she loudly encourages
the character on screen to use some
common sense scream 2 features
previously intelligent characters doing
things that make you want to um scream
at the television like splitting up with
the killer in the vicinity backing up
against a window and going back to
unmask someone when you should just
wrong
the way i see it someone's out to make a
sequel you know cash in on all the movie
murder hoopla says randy as he enjoys
his product placement let's get in to
the things you missed
[Music]
in the first stream i talked about how
the movie started by pulling a page from
alfred hitchcock's psycho by killing off
its poster girl this time the poster
features two more big stars jada pinkett
and sarah michelle gellar jada's
character maureen is the second to die
after her boyfriend just like casey and
sarah's character cece is third also
speaking of pulling a page from psycho
the opening scene of stab adds a part
where casey goes into the shower the
shot of the tap turning on is the same
shot from psycho the rest of the scene
is pretty accurate to what we saw on
screen including the conversation which
begs the question how would the creators
of stab know what transpired that night
unless one of the participants was
actually still alive scream 1 used
halloween as a template a movie that
everybody knows and can understand how
it's being satirized but scream 2
doesn't really offer an equivalent
however stab acts as an in-universe
stand-in for scream 1 and we've seen
something similar in the halloween
franchise in halloween 3 we see that the
original halloween is just a movie in
that universe halloween 3 is also a
famously panned sequel but other than
that there aren't really any
similarities stream had become famous
and there were already movies in
production trying to imitate it so the
challenge was for scream 2 to try to be
the best imitator while the first stream
made its gimmick appearance by having
the killer's quiz casey on scary movies
while being in a scary movie scream 2
tells us that these horror movie fans
are about to be in a movie of their own
by using screen direction stab casey is
seen running to the left towards the
door and then we cuts to phil going
through a door himself this link is the
director's way of telling us that he's
about to be a victim too we hear the
song red right hand by nick cave and the
bad seeds twice in this movie in the
first one it played during the curfew
lockup montage and in two we hear it
right as stab as beginning and as the
delta lambda zeta party disperses
perhaps another link to tell us that the
movie is leaking into reality there are
a lot of instances where things from
scream 2 fill the role for material from
the first one for example sydney's
college mascot is the wildcats a less
specific version of the panthers which
was her high school mascot it plays into
the idea that we have copycat killers
just like how the initial three victims
share a name with the first three
victims in woodsboro sydney once again
gets unwanted attention from the press
because of her past the scene where cece
has attacked at her sorority house is
just like the scene of sydney being
attacked at her actual home and just
like scream one and ghostface pops out
from a closet by the stairs i wonder if
the fact that he hides under the stairs
is a wes craven reference cece's
immediate reaction is to then run up the
stairs just like high school sydney said
that she would some stupid killer
stalking some big breasted girl who
can't act who's always running up the
stairs when she should be going out the
front door the ice cream scene is the
new video store scene in the video store
scene randy directly determines who one
of the killers is by accusing billy who
fires back by asking how do we know
you're not the killer and randy admits
that if this were a scary movie he would
in fact be a prime suspect this time he
correctly identifies mickey as one of
the killers the freaky tarantino film
student but also concedes that he would
likely be a suspect on the same grounds
but if he's a suspect so am i worth
noting in the scene he's also kind of on
the right track when it comes to the
second killer he brings up mrs voorhees
as proof that the killer could be a
female like mrs voorhees from friday the
13th the killer is the mom of another
killer randy's other suspect is gayle
weathers that's what reporters do dewey
he staged the news he's got the right
idea but he's got the wrong reporter
history repeats itself later in the
movie when gail and dewey team up and
gail makes an important discovery while
they're hooking up in the original it's
neil prescott's car and in the sequel
it's mickey's tapes the killer is once
again behind randy look behind you dewey
gets stabbed in the back again gail
blocks the door to the recording studio
so that ghostface can only reach in and
fly it's like sydney in her room mickey
reveals himself as the killer using a
familiar line
surprise sydney just like stew did
during the last 20 minutes of scream
surprise sydney at the end sydney buries
one into mrs loomis's forehead just like
she had with her son and it all ends
with cotton foreshadowing the next stab
film i'll tell you one thing
i'll make a hell of a movie but there is
one easter egg that even i wouldn't have
found if not for this retrospective
documentary
[Music]
i'm sure you noticed the way that
ghostface wipes off the knife in scream
2. it's a signature move established by
stu in the first movie i wanted to bring
it up though because in my video in the
first film i tried to as i do figure out
what the subtext behind this might be
however in the 2011 retrospective still
screaming dane farwell the stunt actor
in that scene offers a simpler
explanation it's a direct cut to me
running through the hall with a clean
knife a west just thought for two
seconds he said we'll wipe the knife off
on camera another thing i talked about
in my first video was relevant cameo
appearances and those seem to have been
given special attention here in 1997.
director of photography peter dumming
plays the popcorn boy screenwriter kevin
williamson is the interviewer on current
edition i never would have noticed this
on my own but matthew lillard who plays
stu in scream used two percent of his
power to make a background cameo at the
party scene which thankfully for me he
brought up in the retrospective
otherwise i would never have known it
was him you know one day i was just
hanging out like go walk in the back of
the party scene and director wes craven
makes another appearance this time as a
doctor at the hospital scene that one i
actually found out about from a fan site
which is coincidentally also called
still screaming the best cameo though is
this one from lev schreiber's dog what a
boy there are a bunch of other cameos
but on things you missed i'm only
interested in ones that have some kind
of significance or something to do with
the movie after a film class discussion
on sequels and imitators of movie
killers gail brushes off the idea of
audience safety being important
are you kidding me it'd be stupid to
pull this movie
all this free press they're gonna have
huge numbers this weekend you either die
a hero or live long enough to see
yourself become the villain despite this
movie's concept being a takeoff of
horror sequels we aren't bombarded with
movie references like we were in screen
instead there's another theme that the
finale centers itself around theater
sydney is a theater major and has a
prominent role in the production of
agamemnon which is advertised all over
the campus
cassandra is one of the great tragic
visionaries of literature she saw it all
coming the wars the murder the madness
she knew she was cursed it was her fate
and she embraced it this might be a
comparison between two unlikely subjects
to be paired horror movie final girls
and greek mythology one of the things
that audiences tend to find ridiculous
about sequels is the fact that the same
characters get themselves into trouble
again it always seems like a huge
coincidence that only exists to extend
the franchise that's why in a lot of
long-running franchises there's some
kind of curse that keeps the killer
coming back again and again the
character sydney plays in agamemnon is
cassandra who is literally cursed by the
greek god apollo in the case of scream
it's obviously not like a magic curse
but rather that sydney is cursed by the
publicity of the horrible things that
have happened to her i do think it's
significant that their whole culture on
campus revolves around these sororities
or as they're sometimes called greek
life in the car crash scene there's some
graffiti of greek letters representing
the sorority where the party took place
earlier delta lambda zeta along with
some text in english that says stab this
but the greek letters are crossed out in
red and this is the scene where that
sorority's pledge hallie gets herself
drossed off by mickey the movie's climax
takes place on the stage where the fall
of troy set is still up this is where
ghostface attacks her on more than one
occasion the greek versus the trojan so
to speak at the end she actually uses
her greek letters given to her by her
boyfriend to protect her to attack
mickey and ultimately get away the play
that she's in is agamemnon which like
stab is the first chapter of a trilogy
scream was also a trilogy from 2000 to
2011.
empire strikes back
better story improved effects not a
sequel part of the trilogy completely
plenty in scream i think i pointed out
like 20 different nightmare on elm
street references but scream 2 seems to
have just one when cotton is arrested by
sydney's bodyguards in the library we
see a book called our dreaming mind
which deals with the science of sleep
and dreams much like how nancy visits a
sleep disorder clinic to try to fix her
freddie fruit
to try to fix her freddy freeman problem
to try to fix her freddy krueger problem
for a minute i also thought this was
freddie's iconic sweater in sid's dorm
room but when i actually compared the
two i realized that they're not the same
i had the same thing happen in sid's
room when i analyzed the first scream i
thought this was chucky's sweater but
eventually realized that the colors
don't match stream two has a girl that
looks kind of like chucky but again the
colors don't match as i did for the
first movie i want to wrap up by talking
about some of the evidence about who the
killers are some of which you may have
missed
first up we've got cc's sorority house
where we can confirm once again that
there are two killers because you can
still hear one ghost face talking on the
phone as the other sneaks through the
front door in the background during
certain chase scenes we hear ghostface
grunting sometimes it sounds male
and at other times the sound is female
but when speaking on the phone we can't
make this determination because of the
voice changer when sydney gets a
ghostface call from deborah salt aka mrs
loomis at the sorority house she hears
this
suggesting that it's someone from
sydney's past like her late
ex-boyfriend's mom and from a filmmaking
standpoint when you make a sequel you
have to include enough information so
that audiences who haven't seen the
first one can still keep up we only see
two scenes from stat the opening and
this scene which reminds us that billy's
mom left him in his dad the only reason
to cut away from the scene that we're in
and focus on that part is if that
information is going to be important
somehow like if billy's mom were to for
example come back deborah also
suspiciously manages to get to the scene
of the crime at the sorority house where
cece was attacked and at the film school
where dewey was attacked before anyone
else maybe because she was already there
but the strongest evidence is actually
evidence for mickey being guilty in
class he argues with the idea that
sequels can be better than the original
of course he would say that the windsor
murders are his sequel to the woodsboro
murderers you know i knew this was
coming
i knew this wasn't over you are not
alone too yeah he would know that this
was coming because he was responsible
the most damning evidence though is the
fact that he always has his video camera
when dewey and gail go to study their
tapes they can see each of the crime
scenes were recorded from ghostface's
point of view the only issue is that he
wasn't the one projecting these tapes he
must have given them to mrs loomis at
some point because he was planning on
getting caught so he could use the trial
to try to blame the movies for his
actions okay i take back what i said the
most damning evidence against mickey is
the fact that we can see him right here
through the eyeholes of the ghostface
mask stream 2 was famously rewritten
during production because the ending
leaked on the internet so the fact that
we have all of these setups is kind of
impressive we're mostly all in agreement
that scream 1 is superior and i think
the idea that the sequel's villain could
just be switched out like that is kind
of a testament to it being a weaker
story however with all of that being
said i guess cotton was going to be one
of the villains originally and i'm sort
of glad that that didn't happen because
his redemption at the end is one of the
best parts and it sets us up for scream
three which i'll be covering next time
on things you missed check out my screen
playlist on the left for that and
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new horrors every week ring the death
bell and make sure you select all
notifications i'll see you in the next
one assuming we both survive
[Music]
[Applause]